[Music]
hi guys how's it going I'm in a hurry
because the Sun is about to set I do
this every time I do a drone unboxing
and I lose all of my daylight but today
we're gonna be unboxing the Phantom 4
Pro I'm pretty excited about this
because it comes with an integrated
screen and it's much brighter for
outdoors and if you've ever full of drug
without any sort of coverage over top of
either your iPhone or whatever it is
that you're flying with it's so
difficult to see in bright situations
but hopefully this little guy will be
bright enough to alleviate all those
issues for all of us let's open it up
set this up I also got myself a nice
little drone back pack so that I can
take this home for the holidays I'm so
glad that it comes with this protective
case again because this is such a great
[Music]
yeah baby look at you though the added
sensors in the new Phantom 4 pro do get
a little reckless when I'm out flying so
thank you for those our controller
they have two different color bag this
time all the charging gear cables
directions the camera looks to be a
little bit larger than the previous
Phantom 4 look at the little screen it
looks just like a little iPhone I just
like this controller is so big it's so
great just carrying that mad at arounds
like it's incredible I also got this
because one of the things with flying
drones if you've never done it before
batteries tend to die quite quickly oh
the battery life is improved on the
Phantom 4 pro and on the Maverick it's
still pretty good you only get about 27
minutes of flight time which in reality
when you're flying is actually quite a
long time so this is the battery charger
they'll allow you to charge three
batteries at the same time gives you a
charging option in a storage option if
you just want to be able to store your
batteries it also has a micro USB
charging port right here I'm going to be
interested to see how the battery life
is on this controller now that they have
this integrated screen because usually
the controller batteries are pretty good
so screen is about the same size as an
iPhone 7 plus it's a little bit smaller
so satisfying let's pick this up
it definitely needs charged get some
agreements I agree
hop on our Wi-Fi oh god this isn't
English that's not English
this isn't English oh my god how do I
use how do I do this this is not English
okay so let's read early to type on this
keyboard so a tip for anybody that is
doing this set up what I've been doing
is I'm actually just holding down the
key and then I can select the letter
because for whatever reason it is
definitely not working well with an
English keyboard but it is working
perfectly fine if I hold down but I can
hold that down for each letter oh no
baby
love that sound so you guys can see it
it's still doing its updates but this is
the Phantom 4 phantom 4 Pro you guys
could see we've got the sensors on the
sides the back front and sensors on the
bottom so basically if you crash this
thing she definitely did have obstacle
of what it's on and here's a control or
comparison controller sighs looks almost
exactly the same same size there's
really not a big difference on the back
though there is an additional few ports
there's a microUSB there's a micro SD
card slot and HDMI out and another USB
slot
Oh
[Music]
don't do that and if that ever does
happen you're gonna have to hop in turn
up obstacle avoidance because it
wouldn't allow me to move it to the left
to the right to the front to the forward
to the back to the right to the down
because the obstacle avoidance was on so
I'd turned that off and gently guide my
baby boy baby girl
whatever your sexy is whatever you
identify with over and be able to land
it here so let's go outside
hello hello no we gotta get the Sun set
you know where do we go where should we
go where should we go
oh we go we actually go anywhere cuz I
can fly for miles so tonight this is my
first time actually flying the Phantom 4
outside of my house so yeah there's that
[Music]
so another things out the controller
isn't super bright I think the screen
brightness is a thousand nits hold on me
find my journal before I continue saying
what I want to say like I think I'm in
the clouds right now
[Music]
I should I bring it down cause it's kind
of windy
[Music]
okay we're out here testing out the
Phantom 4 Pro I've been flying it for
about two weeks now and it's been really
really fun and a lot of people keep
asking me just saying why do you decide
to fly the Phantom 4 Pro over the Mavic
or your phantom 4 mostly I fly the Mavic
when I'm traveling or it's easy just
sort of just throw it in my bag where is
the Phantom 4 is much bigger so it takes
a lot more time to set up it's a lot
bigger clearly so that's one of those
things you have to sort of like plan for
but the mafic is like the everyday drone
like yo you want to go to the mall I got
my drone hey you want to go to the you
wanna go buy some shoes I brought my
drone with me like you know something
like that right yeah so flying with the
integrated monitor controller with
phantom or pro is kind of cool because
it's super bright especially in really
sunny days so it's actually way brighter
than your iPhone so you're able to see a
lot easier a lot of people do fly with
an iPad so it gives you a much larger
screen resolution so you're able to see
a little bit better but I've been flying
the Mavic so much that flying with a
smaller screen it's really not that big
of a deal but if that's something that
you do prefer to do then I definitely
wouldn't get the Phantom 4 with the
integrated screen I like it
I like it's nice I don't to worry about
plenty of iPad let's pack her up I got
to show you guys this backpack it's
incredible I'll put a link in the
description if you guys want to check it
out but I can fit so much stuff in there
it also has a way that you can hang your
phantom off of the back of the backpack
so you'll actually have to take off all
of the propellers
here with these little compartments for
batteries but I want to get a 360 shot
but I can fit all of this stuff in there
these on here you just flip this upside
down
and here's the best part I have a whole
nother drone up here crazy
I loved around this I love it so much
side pockets so I can fit charters in
there here it is it's huge
so I just realized I never ended this
video I had so much fun playing with the
Phantom 4 Pro and what I really do love
about the Phantom 4 Pro is the quality
of the video is incredible it's a lot
more crisp than the Mavic but the Mavic
is so incredible for portability and if
I was to choose between the two I would
definitely go with the mattock because
for me traveling with my drone is super
important I need to be able to have it
with me at all times and not make sort
of a huge ordeal about setting up
propellers and all that kind of stuff
when I want to fly Matic just goes the
Vanderpool Pro though and it's cool I
love the integrated screen especially
when it's bright outside the screen is
so bright and I didn't have any issues
with Sun the only problem that I did
have was trying to film the screen
because there was a lot of glare but for
me looking at the screen flying it was
great so all now I hope you guys enjoyed
this little quick unboxing and review I
filmed this a really long time ago like
way before Christmas I did the unboxing
I figured I would post it anyway because
a lot of you guys we're asking to see it
so here it is
my friend Nathan just got it inspired to
so I am going to beg him to take me and
just watch and fly it because I don't
ever ask people to fly their drones
because I don't trust myself you can
crash your own drone I'll crash my own
drones I don't want to be the one to
crash somebody else's but that being
said ever see you guys in my next video
I like this one I could just attach to
my key ring and this one's a little bit
bigger so this one I'm probably gonna
throw in my luggage or throw this one in
my wallet it's nice and slim so it's
about the width of two credit cards so
these just connect to an iPhone app you
also have the ability to ping them
they'll make a noise so if your item